good morning good morning everybody
happy granite teacher in our live stream
day number 42 I'm a little sick today
I've got to sort of throat some coughing
so this will be a fun exercise today
doing this live stream and the following
one on our twitch channel but just
because you're sick doesn't mean you
can't be grateful it doesn't mean you
can't do what you love so hopefully you
can handle the occasional cough and
throat clearing um will you this daily
guys we do this as a daily reminder for
the things that we're grateful for our
lives things were happy for things that
we want to recognize and show a little
love because grateful entrepreneurs are
happy entrepreneurs a successful
entrepreneurs that I want you to go out
and have a big impact on the world and
it's important as well to think about
the why behind it not just listed off
but ask yourself why you're so grateful
for feel it for each point you know it
doesn't have to take very long but if
you want to get that emotional benefit
of the gratitude exercise then then it's
important to ask yourself why it's so
important so I'm going to start with my
three and then we're going to go to the
live chat do some shoutouts he'll you
guys are great before and fills you
watching afterwards leave it down the
comments below and we're going to join
in that discussion for me I'm grateful
for I'm grateful for a healthy throat
I'm grateful for not being sick I'm
getting for a healthy body I think when
whenever we get sick it's easy to forget
what I think when we're healthy sorry Z
forget what healthy feels like and we
figure out our other problems and what's
going on in the world around this but
when we're sick kind of things slow down
head gets little foggy and so I'm
grateful for most of the time when I am
healthy and can speak normally and can
process clearly that's going to be a fun
league of legends live stream with my
head up in the clouds um but I think
I'll still do well I'm pretty I'm
feeling confident so I'm grateful for
most of the days that I have a good
throat I'm able to talk clearly able to
do my videos and I'm pretty healthy to
the help entrepreneurs number 2 i'm
grateful for democracy my American
friends are off to go vote today in an
important election and we'll see what
happens I'm in Canada so you know we
don't have an election time for a while
I've no interruptions coming up but I
mean I love my country I think it's the
greatest country in the world you guys
watch you may disagree but I'm just
grateful for the opportunity to pick our
leaders you know a lot of places you
don't get the pic and a lot of countries
are are not doing so hot right now
because their leaders and so I'm
grateful that I may not always agree
with the decisions that our leaders take
but I've been feel that I have the power
to vote for the leader that I want in
influence others to vote along side as
well so grateful for democracy and
encouraging all the American viewers out
here today to go and cast your vote
because it's important and number 3 i'm
grateful for for light I don't know if
it I don't know do I appear brighter
than usual today uh I hope so i've had
an electrician coming yesterday for
basically the whole day and installed
the whole bunch of different lights in
the office i have a new fixture that has
12 light bulbs only six of them are in
right now I find that when I'm when I'm
super sensitive to my environment and I
can't work well in low light
environments my dad is like a vampire
and can work in he loves the dark he
works in the dark J reyez works in the
dark too i like i like the bright i
finally if it's too dark i get a
headache so i got this new license Talde
and when I'm filming I have Sun coming
here and all this
daylight from the bulbs coming here so
it balances out it so I'm super pumped
for that in having a well-lit
environment to work out so those are my
three I'm grateful for having a healthy
throat and just being healthy for
democracy and grateful for light we've
got what six minutes let's see what you
guys are doing before in the live chat
before we move on with our day starting
us off zeno the first quote exceeds from
zain Oh too bad you will be here but
thanks for certain us off so I didn't
have to see who start this off I guess
it got cut off zeno is grateful for one
mm-hmm knowing Evans book will be in my
hands in less than a month that's it i'm
pretty excited you brought a smile to my
face ain't no to jen being able to take
over for Rishi is Evans business Q&A
co-host I think she'll do a fantastic
job just like what she has yeah jen is
subbing in for the next I think it's
three weeks when we she's away so that
should be fun for those of you want to
join us in the twitch livestream in five
minutes now and three a video i edited
being on evans channel called what is
your one word yes it's a shameless plug
it's a great video i recommend going to
check it out and thank you for that Xena
really means a lot that you made that my
gratitude is all about Evan what has
been doing i just noticed and jen doing
a fantastic job was an unintended pun
what's the pun to do a fantastic job is
that a pun i don't know if my brains
working properly today ah meh meh meh
aville mahal veld led us off i guess
he's not here um thank for Evans book
Jen's energy and your video Jay Rogers
thankful for so many herbs and spices
that add variety to food it's true at
this amazing steak that Nina made last
night and I put a little bit of extra
salt on it mmm my mouth is watering as
I'm saying this right now I gotta go eat
some steak for creativity artistry and
inspiration which rises all endeavors
for high value high impact team members
who go the extra mile
I love it best you Pro shout out to Zane
on Jerry's you guys are always early
love it it's true it's a good group here
we are grateful for one another
beautiful day that allows us to make a
deposit in our future growth for the
internet that allows us to connect with
belief nation 11 and 3 our website very
cool que el bien it's been a while
things I'm grateful for number one an
amazing trip to orlando with my boo sang
with my boo thing that has continued on
to miami which is where i'm writing from
now very cool thank you for joining in
from miami number two grandma hooking it
up with breakfast and coffee every
morning craving a coffee too Alex came
over he was sick so I sent him home like
Alex is sick don't get me sick it's like
well you're already sick the don't get
be MARSOC but usually brings me coffee
so he didn't bring me coffee now craving
my coffee I want my grandmother come
bring me some coffee que el bien send
your grandma here to make me breakfast
and coffee three spending quality time
with my youngest brother cool do the do
the contact tubidy here with the family
wasn't able to join the live chat last
week but I'm here now 11 welcome back
what else what else what else Melissa
hello good morning believe nation I'm
grateful for clean clothes to put on
that's pretty important I like looking
to my closet and same hmm which
sweatshirt am I going to wear today I
have like 20 of these so maybe more have
to check but I love clean clothes I reef
up for the money magnet that I am I love
that Melissa I'm grateful for my parents
and brothers because they make my life
complete very cool what else Mitchell
good morning what's up Mitchell relaxing
sleep station hey gang welcome back what
do we got what do we got I thought it's
not something from relax and sleep
station oh it just skipped again every
time it skips number one grateful for
the morning routine
that I that I have that gets my day up
to a good start looking for the cool
weather that we continue to be having
which is so much better for my health
and three grateful fermenters like Evan
and Tim Schmoyer that provide him with
information and inspirations very cool
I'm honored to be associated with Tim
are actually talking to him in an hour
and a half so that should be fun to uh
Mitchell today I'm grateful for great
full for one health to all so grateful
for this channel love that thank you
Mitchell and three the ability to vote
love that que el bien Sam I need to
workout exercise helps with the healing
process all right we'll do some jumping
jacks for que el bien what else we got
blackjack s I'm thankful for a new day
my health and strength and finding my
one word persevere very cool i like that
much my co-host coming up I'm grateful
four legs that I can stretch and spread
and dance and run with movement gives me
so much joy I love very cool guys night
n that's it we're going to end on jen's
note and then i'm going to go in with
jen on the league of legends live stream
business Q&A we're going to answer your
questions while Jay rise and I play a
game of League of Legends and hopefully
pull out a victory once we've been
Master Yi so thank you guys for watching
if I don't see you on the live stream I
hope you have an amazing day hope you
are healthy hope you go and vote do
something impactful to help but the
people around you I believe in you I
hope you continue to believe in yourself
and whatever your one word is much love
I'll see you soon